[Music]
about a year ago it was maybe
the hottest commodity in the country who
could forget images
like this americans buying up toilet
paper in the early
and on certain days of the pandemic
while big name brands dominate store
shelves there was enough room for a
small startup
headed by two sisters to roll out their
own line of
tp christina raffini has their story
when sisters nandigi and luis issa roll
up to deliver a box of their
environmentally friendly bamboo toilet
paper
people get a little weird we would go to
people's house and just drop them off
and they'll get so excited it felt like
we were
publishing clearhouse like but instead
of check and we come into your with a
box of like toilet paper
people be jumping up and down the
excitement could be because lore tush is
tree-free hypoallergenic and more
sustainable than the traditional stuff
or it could be because they arrive just
in time we try to be fast just in case
you know
just in case they just in case they
really need it
the sisters do most of their business in
this cramped thousand square foot
storage space in downtown
baltimore their initial goal was to find
a cheap renewable product
that could help their community go green
we started to
research what kind of sustainable
product we can
introduce to people who look like us and
after a bunch of research
we landed on toilet paper why is that we
just try to figure out what's something
like an everyday use that somebody can
easily exchange
and afford and afford yeah with a loan
from a friend and money from savings
they sourced about seven thousand roles
from an overseas producer
then covet hit and the economy started
to unravel
once covet happens we decided to instead
of selling it just to give it away to
our community
how come because we know what it feels
like we know what it feels like to lose
a job we know what it feels like to have
no money
and we know what it feels like to not be
able to afford essential things
they gave away about 5 000 roles to
anyone who needed them
other local businesses started to take
notice if we're going to invest
in a local company we want to make sure
that they have
some type of other impact right in the
community that to us was very appealing
jason bass is the director of culture
and impact at revival
a boutique hotel where every bathroom is
now
well stocked with laura tush our first
order was actually a year supply uh
wow you went all for it we went all
forward we wanted to make sure we
supported it at the gate and the
response has been
fantastic like people have noticed your
toilet paper they've actually noticed it
they've written reviews about the toilet
paper and some people have walked out
with a fresh roll of toilet paper i mean
i guess if people are stealing it you
know they like it right
yeah that's one way of finding out if
you have a fan
the sisters are now in talks with other
hotels across the east coast
it's important to see that these small
businesses these black owned businesses
are getting supported by large
organizations
and they are capable of meeting the
demand and although the original idea
was to reach an
often overlooked group the issa sisters
say switching to bamboo toilet paper
even if it's not their brand is a great
way to give a sheet
about the planet we still want to reach
people who look like us
but we want to reach everyone who wants
the opportunity to do something
different
you can be sustainable too it's not for
one type of person
yeah anyone can do this just find your
way in
yeah and then you can have fun while
you're doing it yeah be yourself
or as it says on each package wipe on
player wipe one
for cbs this morning saturday christina
raffini
baltimore wipe on
playa love it can you spare a square
it's a great great story with respect
though i think we can
sometimes bamboo not
quite as because you've used this before
comfy
as but what a great idea it is a great
idea
it's for the planet graffiti has got to
bring
greenhouse gases down to zero i'm just
saying that